Das ist schon ein bisschen verrückt eine forschungsgruppe sucht eigentlich nach planet 9
dabei liegt aber der jupiter genau vor der vermuteten fundstelle vom planet 9 und stattdessen quasi im vorbeigehen
findet das forschungsteam zwölf neue gestürmt in unserem sonnensystem alle infos dazu jetzt den blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Auch so funktioniert wissenschaft man sucht nach etwas und findet etwas ganz anderes so seiner forschungsgruppe
um scott sheppard von der carnegie institution for science gegangen
eigentlich wollten sie endlich eine spur vom planeten entdeckt man vermutet ja dass es sich dabei um einen gesteinsplaneten
handelt und dass er wohl den vierfachen durchmesser der erde hat und maximal zehn mal so groß ist wie
unser heimatplanet er muss sich nach ansicht vieler forschungsteam wohl am äußersten rande des sonnensystems versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen verschiedene objekte in dieser region lassen darauf schliessen konkret geht es um rund 20 größere objekte
im kupfergürtel ein gebiet außerhalb der neptun waren nach schätzungen von astronomen und astronomen sind dort zahlreiche
kleine und wohl mehr als
70.000 objekte zu finden die einen durchmesser von mehr als 100 kilometern haben weswegen man planet 9 bis heute trotz
intensiver suche noch nicht direkt beobachten konnte das liegt wohl an seiner enormen distanz zur sonne amerikanische
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen vom institute of technology
california haben berechnet dass die bahn vom planet neuen den planeten zu dem zeitpunkt seiner dichtesten er wohl immer noch
700 mal weiter an der sonne vorbei führt als die erde inzwischen wurden viele informationen über den mysteriösen riesenplaneten
analysiert und mit hilfe von computermodellen
komplizierte
simulationen erstellt ein team hatte das komplette letzte jahr analysiert wie planet 9 mit anderen planeten und dem rest des
sonnensystems inter geht dabei sei man schon ein gutes stück weitergekommen seine mögliche position am himmel ein zu kämpfen dieses jahr
findet die systematische suche am himmel statt aber
bisher ist man noch nicht fündig geworden wobei so ganz stimmt es ja nicht jetzt hat eben ein forschungsteam quasi als
zufallsfund zwölf neue jupiter monde entdeckte 11 der
monde haben einen durchmesser von einem bis drei kilometer neun davon sind teil eines jahr waren mond schwarz in einiger entfernung
zu dem gasplaneten
der alle zwei jahre einmal um den jupiter kreis wahrscheinlich liegt der ursprung dieses schwarz in drei größeren objekten die einmal
auseinander gebrochen sind zwei der entdeckten monde gehören zu einer gruppe die dichter um die planeten kreist und nur ein jahr für eine umrundung
benötigen einer der entdeckten monde ist allerdings ein sonderling er umkreist den jupiter alle anderthalb jahre und ist mit weniger als einem kilometer der
kleinsten bisher entdeckte jupitermond seine umlaufbahn ist wohl ziemlich instabil und dass das forschungsteam vermutet eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit
der kollision mit anderen objekten mit den neu entdeckten monden sind jetzt insgesamt
79 monde bekannt die um den gasriesen
kreisen ist er ist damit der planet im sonnensystem mit den meisten monden und es ist nicht unwahrscheinlich dass
noch mehr in der nächsten zeit gefunden werden der jupiter ist übrigens so riesig und so hell dass er ganz leicht mit bloßem auge am
nachthimmel entdeckt werden kann
und er ist auch so groß dass er sogar als kleine scheibe zu sehen ist versucht es mal
und schreibt mir in den kommentare ob ihr den gasplaneten
am himmel entdeckt habt das ist ja inzwischen mit dem der ein oder anderen app ziemlich leicht hinzubekommen
ja und wenn ihr kein video mehr verpassen wollte also wenn erfahren wollt wenn neue monde zum beispiel gefunden werden um den jupiter
dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die kaputt arburg sie auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen und das täglich und das garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten noch mal schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die klopper vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken planet 9 die schlinge zieht sich zu bis dann
bleibt dran